after the war there was a real silence
and shame and not wanting to talk about
this episode you still get a little
reluctance of people to want to talk
about this more than a hundred thousand
men women and children all of Japanese
ancestry removed from their homes in the
Pacific Coast state two-thirds of the
evacuees are American citizen by right
of birth the rest are there Japanese
born parents and grandparents the
Japanese internment camps established on
the west coast under the Roosevelt
administration are well documented but
far less well known are the camps
established in Hawaii immediately
following the attack on Pearl Harbor
Japan and the US had been kind of on
this road towards war since the early
part of the 1900s and because of that
and because of this large resident
Japanese population in Hawaii there was
this fear of what was going to happen
should war come between the two
countries so since the 1920s various
intelligence agencies the Office of
Naval Intelligence the Army g2 the FBI
were kind of keeping tabs on the local
Japanese population by the eve of Pearl
Harbor
all of these agencies which were kind of
coordinated the FBI was took the
preeminent role they already knew
exactly what they were gonna do in the
event of war and indeed when Pearl
Harbor was was attacked on December 7
that day they sprung into action and
started detaining people on those lists
that they've been compiling they kind of
had a point system where a buddhist
priest or shinto that got you on the
list if you were christian not so much
right because that was seen as more more
american quote/unquote Japanese language
school teachers newspaper editors like
my grandfather
one of the biggest categories were what
they called consular agents which sounds
ominous but what it really meant were
immigrant generation community leaders
who were sort of go-betweens between the
community and the consul general's
office because among other prohibitions
Japanese immigrants could not become US
citizens in Hawaii in particular the
story gets really buried
the war on the mainland I think it was
understood that you did nothing wrong I
mean everybody who is of Japanese
descent got thrown into camp here it was
just select people who God or select
families they were affected and I think
for many years members of those families
didn't want to talk about it because at
some level they felt like they were
culpable in some way or they had done
something wrong
even you know in the work that we've
done recently to try to uncover that
story you still get a little reluctance
of people to want to talk about this
because so much went unspoken for so
many years very little was known about
the camps themselves until now we found
people who said it's over here no it's
over there but more people we found who
said I didn't know Hawaii had internment
camps and even some who said I didn't
know Hawaii had internees Jane Cora Hara
is a researcher at the Japanese cultural
center of Hawaii she made it her
personal mission to uncover as much as
she could about Hawaii's mysterious
internment camps here was this important
part of history slipping away very
thinly documented very few people
knowing about it and it was in danger
being lost it's a very well hidden camp
now that we know where it is and it
isn't until you're almost on top of it
but you realize you're there these are
some of the ruins of the camp discovered
by Cora Hara and the museum they're now
working with the landowners who
volunteered to open the site up to the
public within the next year when you're
there then you understand what they must
have gone through it's hot and it's
humid the internees called it G Co
kudani which means hell valley once you
get that sense you think why were they
here
you know we study history not
specifically to learn about the past but
to learn about the present in the future
I think one of the reasons there's been
so much focus on the japanese-americans
story during World War two is because
the obvious parallels to what we see
happening today especially in the wake
of what happened after 9/11 the
combos reflexive desire to kind of
demonize certain segments of the
population who just look like the enemy
it's very important that we learn
lessons from history especially when
they have big ideas like this where
discrimination when you don't even know
the other person is has this very
negative impact on people and you should
be sensitive to others and try to treat
each other with respect and dignity and
that's why I think is a timeless
important life lesson